poesia já deu bom dia pra sua mãe angela
no quarto dela não é mãe pontinha vai
rodar mão na tua cara meu cabelo de
facto parece passar chapinha galera não
6 horas da manhã eu ainda não dormir ou
trabalhando isso não estava escrevendo
num monólogo câmera pesada da desgraça
está imaginando aquino muitos anos atrás
hora que estava guardando a assistir
todo mundo corre conta que quando era
pequeno era muito ansioso ainda sou era
muito silva ela acorda mais cedo a ligar
na globo está passando é curso 2007 uns
caras montando um motor de um fusca meu
deu ao momento da sua vida você pare e
pense 5 na tudo que eu queria agora vê
alguém de montando um motor de um fusca
como se não bastasse e aquela voz índice
assim a atenção agora é hora da revisão
ou não bastava o programa toda hora o
cara vai fazer a revisão de montar
montando fusca na o povo dessa [ __ ] a
botar no sbt do criança esperança
assistindo desenhos e do tipo a escola
está passando siga bem caminhoneiro é eu
acho que o motor do fusca estava legal e
alcances tivessem nada aí acaba aquela
porcaria vai iniciando a começar o
desenho que toda lei
aí entra a desgraça da programação local
o autor de meu deus e 8 e de oração a
criança eu só queria assistir um dancing
é você pega mais um mais um e não dá pra
você não dá pra você achar alguma coisa
interessante na programação local não tá
por qq problema foi o local é uma bosta
e meio que só tem que ser ruim e seguro
programa local eu só gosta de falar
graças à atenção que se acorda de manhã
e ia ser nem sei se mesmo em meio à
notícia que tem um homem morre
atropelado por um caminhão que em 170
quilômetros por hora na rodovia da br
3036 usavam ficaram espalhadas pela
rodovia veja as imagens com quem
demonstra a notícia boa porque vai ter
um plantão na globo a 50 papa
o papa falava pra mudar toda a cidade de
teresina piauí conseguiu passar mais de
uma hora e meia no celular conversando
com a namorada com um celular contendo
um chip da tim
isso mesmo na tim o jovem conta que
obteve dificuldade nas 75 primeiras
ligações a ligação costumava cair depois
do primeiro minuto mas na ligação de
número 76 tudo ocorreu como combina
papaloapan não tem é um pouco querido é
só a extinção da linha de pré escola eu
estava de manhã eu deus do céu quem foi
a pessoa que deixou ser humano que criou
essa coisa de estudar de manhã a gente
criança criança a criança tem um cérebro
de pensar depois que quer que a
actividade brincar com as pessoas que
lidam com a questão gostar de manhã que
o bom só que o monte meu pai graças a
deus fui inteligente não deixou fazer
jardim pré escolar e no fim nessa bosta
gente foi a primeira séculos o hardcore
como que foi massa eu não fiz pra escola
eu não fiz jardim jardim um jardim do
jardim [ __ ] que pariu a eterna primeira
série tem que todas as outras pessoas na
1ª série já tinha estudado emprego estou
lá para a infância jardim da escola
james colado para scola ea professora
passar uma tarefa pra gente gente aqui é
para quem de vocês é um elefante é pra
vocês pintaram um elefante com a cor
correspondente a um elefante se eu pegar
a rolar pintava ela foi de cinza que ela
foi assim eu acho engraçado você dá um
dever para o ps fazer e falar olha tem
que pintar o elefante o meia hora estava
o rabo do elefante rosa assoreados um
corpo amarelo ea toma verde eu não sei
de onde é com a criança que o elefante
dessa corpo e eu pintava e ficávamos o
farol é um idiota um imbecil uma lupi
também é feito um monte de corrupção de
graças a deus como essa escura na bocha
por aqui me perdi meu desejo não
gostamos tese passarinho que só é esse
ou eu nome dele e se sua sonda minha
aquele júri da caixa bicharada no campo
coral corre cocô de cachorro latindo de
mais do que a prevista tchau sujeita a
deus senhor tiso hora
na verdade a nata garrafa lata na
turismo mtur e andrey e freia lalala
batata bochecha capilar apenas lá papel
não era um dia o meu nariz
como é um bombom e também fazer nada
cheio de apodi mais de infância foi
muito boa essa a deus vou falar muita
coisa além brey gente amanhã domingo dia
e só amanhã domingo dia 6 de abril às
quatro horas da tarde vou fazer um
encontro de fãs aqui em teresina é que
vai ser vai ser lá na potycabana naquele
palco lá digitais não grande palco sem
pequeno de capital que fica da infância
andamento assim é assim então pra quem
vai pra que vai ser assim com uma galera
uma galera me chamou pra gente arrecadar
dinheiro para poder comprar o ovo de
páscoa pra poder dar uma criança carente
então se você de teresina e quer me ver
e tocar ainda tirar uma foto você eu
queria que você fosse a potycabana
naquele palco centenário e traz amanhã
dia 6 de abril domingo e eu queria que
você levar sua contribuição zinha se
pincelar r$5 e r$10 esta minha entende
ele vai dar pra comprar qualquer voz e
tempo a lanchar na escola tem né amor
vez passaram de se tomar coca-cola
morrer passando esse machado vai então
ser guarda em 15 reais da ai se eu vou
gravar a gente entregar esses ovos nos
próximos veio também total marcada
amanhã domingo de 6 de abril às quatro
horas da tarde lá na potycabana aquele
palco em pequeno que tem lá atrás lá
depois skates lá no final e você leva a
contribuição zinho não tiver pode também
em pó assim eu quero que você leva para
ajudar vamos lá eu quero
você comédia aqui embaixo que você mais
gostava de fazer na sua infância começa
aqui em baixo
gente é então aconteceu uma coisa minha
pai e às vezes no youtube não entrega o
meu vídeo pra todo mundo tão muitas
pessoas que o canal mais de 800 mil
pessoas criem e às vezes não chega para
todo mundo é muito bom você mexer nas
redes sociais o primeiro link na
descrição do vídeo é minha página no
facebook muitos de vocês não curtiram a
página é bom você conta que a elvis ao
jogo lá o segundo minc o meu twitter
também jogou lá na ucsal vídeo o
terceiro link é o meu instagram toda vez
tem vídeo novo tiro print do vídeo além
de ter várias fotos sensuais as melhores
fotos você já viu uma sua vida você me
segue estável também em baixo está
ganhando é o meu perfil do facebook o
perfil normal de usuário então veio a
ser assistidos ouvido eu sei
pressionando a melhor alternativa
bastante diversão hoje é a primeira vez
que está assistindo o vídeo eu sei que
não inscrever se também tiver menos vai
saber seria o do entrega é mas é bom
você se inscreva
tá vendo meu dicionário executar aquele
que dá um like nesse vídeo pela minha
infância ser bambu e stand alec do meu
filho
o papa está obrigado e tchau mês seu
coração